الممثله والموديل الاسبانيه هبه بوك زوجه
اللاعب المغربي اشرف حكيمي من وقت ما تم
اتهام زوجها بقضيه الاغتصاب كل الانظار
عليها مع انها ما علقت ولد كلمت عن
الموضوع ولا حتى كان لها اي رده فعل واتضح
انها كانت مقدمه رسميا طلب طلاق من قبل ما
يتم اتهامه بقضيه الاغتصاب باسابيع اليوم
هبه عبوق متصدره محركات البحث والمنصات
والسبب فيديو متداول لها خلينا نشوفه مع
بعض
الفيديو اللي شفتوه تم تداوله بشكل كبير
جدا على المنصات وقلب الدنيا والنشافته
وانقسموا في الاراء بين اللي قال لها
برافو وهذه رده فعل متوقعه وبين من عنون
الفيديو زوجه حكيمه تتخلى عنه في اوقاته
العصيبه وبين اللي اعتبروها بتهاجم زوجها
ولكن المفاجاه كانت وقت ما بحثوا الناس عن
حقيقه الفيديو اللي تبين انه الفيديو صحيح
ومو صحيح كيف يعني الفيديو اللي هبه فعليا
لكنه اولا موجده تاريخه يعود لي 17 فبراير
وقت ما كانت هبه عبوه في حفل نظمته شركه
بلغاري بعيده او بعيدها الخمسه او سبعين
والفيديو منشور على الموقع الاسباني
نوباماس يعني قبل قضيه الاغتصاب اللي
انتشرت في 25 فبراير اما ليه بنقول مو
صحيح لانه الترجمه اللي طالعه على الفيديو
ما لها اي علاقه بقضيه الاغتصاب اصلا فهبه
كانت بتجاوب صحفي سالها عن اولادها والفرق
بينهم شوفوا الان الترجمه الصحيحه للمقطع